unrest in the streets of Beirut running
battles in the heart of the Lebanese
capital police moved in after hundreds
of men allied with political parties in
power attacked anti-government
demonstrators who have been in the
streets for almost two weeks
demanding the ruling elites leaves
office the Prime Minister sandal Harry D
has now handed his resignation letter to
the president
for 13 days the Lebanese people have
waited for a decision for a political
solution that would stop the
deterioration
I have tried during this period to find
a way out to listen to the people's
voice and to protect the country from
economic security and social dangers
today I will not hide it from you I have
reached a dead end it is time for us to
have a big shock to face the crisis the
crisis is threatening civil peace the
protest movement doesn't enjoy the
support of the entire country Hezbollah
is among a number of groups backing the
government they chant the name of their
leader Hassan Nasrallah the Iranian back
movement believes there is a campaign to
topple the governing coalition to change
the balance of power in favor of a
pro-western alliance protesters denied
those accusations definitely some people
who try to take advantage of this entire
revolution and movement whereby they
would try to ride this wave and it's
normal but the majority of the people on
the streets are not affiliated with any
political party there are celebrations
in the streets how did his resignation
is seen as a welcome first step but what
protesters are asking for is radical
change early elections and an end to
political sectarianism easier said than
done the question is will this trigger
now a process by which Hezbollah which
is the critical player in the background
as well as the president Michell own and
his party and his son-in-law Gibran
Basile will those people agree to a
technocratic government that would mean
giving up power so far the governing
Alliance says it will be toppled only
through constitutional means
Hariri maybe hoping his decision to
resign will pressure his coalition
partners to make concessions a Hezbollah
led government needs political cover
from someone like Harry Lee who enjoys
the support of the international
community what began as a spontaneous
protest movement is now a political
crisis that spilled onto the streets
Lebanon's fault lines are deep and it's
unclear what happens next a political
vacuum a precarious situation a divided
Street and economy grinding to a halt
Lebanon has been here before and like in
the past it is the security of the
country which is facing the biggest risk
let's not bring in Zana for an update
from Beirut so what has been the impact
of the high dat resignation on the
streets of Beirut zina
well as you can imagine they're
welcoming this they're calling this a
victory what they have been demanding
release for the government to resign and
for early elections to be held they want
to get rid of a ruling elite that has
been in power for what thirty years now
since the days of the civil war they
believe that they're corrupt they
believe that they've mismanaged the
country so people here are welcoming it
but they're also realizing how dangerous
it is to remain in the streets as you
saw in our package a short while ago
they came under attack by supporters of
the government so now civil society
groups protesters they're talking about
the possibility of opening roads no
longer blocking roads across the country
and instead focus their protest action
outside government institutions and most
likely demonstrate in in some squares
across the country so it is a very
dangerous divide that the Prime Minister
has now resigned he submitted his
resignation to the president the
president has still not spoken or
reacted to that yet we understand he is
going to give his reaction tomorrow on
whether or not he's going to accept that
resignation or whether or not some sort
of a compromise can be reached in order
to avoid a very dangerous political
vacuum in this country but Dana so like
you're saying this is not it for the
protesters because they had not only
demanded Hariri's resignation but a
whole series of other resignations as
well
yes it's a crisis that is far from over
but at the end of the day there their
demands really it's easier it's easier
said than done they're up against a
political elite who controls security
forces even the security agencies in
Lebanon are divided they're affiliated
with the different political parties so
the danger is there those in power
they're clinging on to power the message
has been so far you can't topple us from
the street if you want to topple us you
have to topple us through constitutional
means our constitutional tools because
we won an election in 2018 and it was
legit illegitimate election you see the
problem is those in power now believe
that this is a campaign not just to
improve the conditions and the country
but this campaign has a political agenda
and that is to change the balance of
power in this country because right now
those in power are ally to Iran and some
opposition politicians have been riding
the wave of popular anger and those
politicians are allied with the
pro-western camp so it is a very serious
political crisis we've seen as similar
crises like this in the past Lebanon has
been to the brink on more than one
occasion but they've pulled back but the
question is can a compromise be reached
we're expected to hear from the
Secretary General of Hezbollah on Friday
it will be his third speech really since
the start of this protest movement 13
days ago what is he going to say is he
going to try to calm the streets or is
he going to make an announcement that
will instigate even more anger right now
Hezbollah and and its partners really
have lost a lot of support in the street
especially when their supporters are
seen attacking peaceful protesters who
are camped out in the streets across the
country okay Dana huzzah thank you for
that update from Beirut